-Our next guest is
the National Book Award
winning author of her
critically acclaimed novels
"Salvage the Bones"
and "Sing, Unburied, Sing."
Her fantastic new novel,
"Let Us Descend,"
was published today.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Jesmyn Ward.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-It's good to be here.
-I'm so happy to have you.
I asked you backstage --
are you relieved
once a book is written?
And you were very honest,
and you said you'd be relieved
when the press is over.
-Yes.
-Well, thank you very much
for getting through it with us.
This -- I know people have
told you this over the years,
and it's something
that I believe, as well.
Your characters stay with people
long after
they've read your books.
Is that something --
Is that a compliment
that you enjoy hearing?
Is that something you're trying
to do when you're writing?
-Yes.
Yes, because I think
that literature
and that stories
act in a way that...
other mediums don't, right?
I think they allow readers to
sink into a world with a person
and to feel like they're living
that reality with that person.
And I think that the people
that I write about,
the characters
are worthy of
that kind of regard, so...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know -- When you were here
for your National Book Award
winning book,
"Sing, Unburied, Sing,"
that's 2017.
You'd started this book.
-Yes.
-And I know it was
a very difficult book to write,
and it's about
very difficult themes.
I also want to say
I found it very easy to read,
which is a credit
to the beautiful way you write.
But can you talk about
getting over
that hurdle of addressing
sort of the themes
and the difficult histories
that you're addressing in this?
-Right. This...
It was really difficult
to write this book
in part because
I'd never written about anyone
who didn't have a lot
of physical agency, right?
I mean, Annis is
the main character in here,
and she's very constrained
because she's
an enslaved person, right?
But in the writing of the book,
I began to discover that she has
other types of agency, right?
She has emotional agency.
She has imaginative agency.
She has the agency of memory.
She also has a type
of spiritual agency.
So I think that
all of these agencies combined
gave her a way
to move through the world
that was not confined, right.
that was not constrained
by the system of slavery.
And I think it made it --
Hopefully it will make it easier
for readers to read
because they can experience
all of those freedoms
and agencies with her.
-There is, you know,
obviously a great deal
of tragedy in this book,
a great deal of grief
and the processing of grief,
but it's also
a very hopeful book.
When you're writing it,
do you know these are all things
that you want to make sure
exist all at once?
Like, there's no obviously
neat endings,
and it's not like
one section is about this,
one section is about that.
Is it always important for you
to have it sort of
under the same umbrella?
-I think so. I mean...
You know, like, she -- I --
Annis is not a victim.
And she's also --
Because a victim --
When a person
is portrayed as a victim,
they're flattened, right?
They're just victorious,
and that's it.
But she's also not -- She's not
only a survivor either, right?
Because when someone
is only a survivor,
then their experience
is also flattened, right?
I wanted her to be
as complicated and complex
as I could possibly make her.
So she experiences friendship,
she experiences connection,
she has lovers, you know,
at the same time
that she also feels grief
and feels longing
and, you know, misses her
community and misses friends.
So there's -- I want all of that
to exist at the same time
because I think that reflects
how complicated we all are.
-When you write such a sort of
multi-dimensional character
like this that does have
this great wealth of humanity,
do you find when you're writing
the character is telling you
about themselves
or do you find
that you're putting yourself
into the character?
-I think there's a little bit
of both happening, right?
Because whenever I write,
I always feel like the character
who is speaking
is sitting here
and telling me the story.
So in part I'm channeling them.
But at the same time,
I'm also, I think,
pulling on my own experience
to try to understand some of
what they are going through.
And I definitely --
I think this book is --
as far as my novels go --
is the book that is most,
I think, informed
by my experience.
-After a day where you feel
as though you've done
very good writing,
what do you do
at the end of it?
Like, when you finish --
when you like --
Do you write out longhand
or laptop? Is it...
-Laptop?
-Alright. Laptop.
You close the laptop.
You're feeling good.
What's the next thing you do?
-Uh...I...
I do several --
There are several different ways
that I waste time
and cut off my brain.
-It's very -- I think that's
what we all want to hear,
is that you also waste time.
-Yes, yes.
-Sometimes when prolific writers
who have great skill come on,
we want to also know
that they will --
"Yeah. I look at my phone."
-Right, right, right.
-So thank you.
You're giving us great relief
by saying that, as well.
-Good.
-Also I want to,
before we let you go,
point out if people missed it.
This is very exciting.
This was just named
an Oprah Book Club pick.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, uh...
And once again, I'm --
Nothing makes me happier
than when my tastes
are in line with Oprah.
And I think we both
have excellent taste.
And it's really just
a wonderful, wonderful book.
And it's so happy --
I'm so happy to have you back.
Thank you so much, Jesmyn.
-Thank you.
-You guys, that's Jesmyn Ward.
"Let Us Descend"
is available now
wherever you buy your books,
but please support
local and independent
booksellers.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."